condolences to those so terribly injured
in this terrorist attack and to the many
killed and the families so many families
of the victims we stand in absolute
solidarity with the people of the United
Kingdom so many young beautiful innocent
people living and enjoying their lives
murdered by evil losers in life
I won't call them monsters because they
would like that term they would think
that's a great name I will call them
from now on losers because that's what
they are they're losers and we'll have
more of them but they're losers just
remember that this is what I've spent
these last few days talking about during
my trip overseas our society can have no
tolerance for this continuation of
bloodshed we cannot stand a moment
longer for the slaughter of innocent
people and in today's attack it was
mostly innocent children the terrorists
and extremists and those who give them
aid and comfort must be driven out from
our society forever this wicked ideology
must be obliterated and I mean
completely obliterated and the innocent
life must be protected all innocent
lives life must be protected all
civilized nations must join together to
protect human life and the sacred right
of our citizens to live
in safety and in peace